bonsoir frédéric vidal grâce à l'aider
mais cachent des facs qui s'est
poursuivie ce matin à grenoble et à
montpellier at il eu raison du mouvement
étudiant alors ce qui s'est produit ce
matin à grenoble et montpellier c'est de
nature différente
montpellier il n'y avait plus l'étudiant
et c'était simplement un constat des
dégâts qu'ils avaient qui avait été
engendrés ces dernières semaines qui
s'est produit sur sur grenoble président
de l'université a effectivement demandé
à ce que un site puisse être rendue aux
étudiants et aux enseignants de manière
à ce que les choses se déroulent
normalement
alors l'association s'est apprécié
vraiment université par université
globalement quand même est-ce que vous
estimez effectivement que ces déblocages
qui se succèdent y en aura peut-être
d'autres encore
markelov de la faim ont eu raison de ce
mouvement
non moi je crois que une fois de plus un
il faut distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer les endroits où un petit
nombre de personnes ont confisqué
l'université ont commis des violences
des dégâts etc et où le président
d'université estime qu'il n'est plus en
capacité parce que parfois il n'a plus
le même accès aux locaux d'assurer la
sécurité des personnes et des biens est
donc là évidemment eh bien ils demandent
à la police
une intervention et c'est à ce moment là
le rôle de la préfecture de juger de
l'opportunité de l'intervention
et puis il ya des endroits où c'est le
débat qui a lieu ça c'est normal dans
les universités et où il ya des
assemblées générales où toutes les
opinions peuvent s'exprimer et c'est une
différence fondamentale avec les
assemblées générales dans lesquels seuls
quelques individus ont la parole et les
autres sont exclues et ne peuvent
parfois même pas entrer un point assez
précis aujourd'hui de la situation dans
les universités françaises
est ce que vous savez précisément
combien sur toute la france aujourd'hui
bloqué ce soir encore alors on a trois
universités qui sont qui sont bloqués
sur soixante dix ans vient sur 73
universités et
université en fait c'est plusieurs
facultés plusieurs sites à peu près 400
400 sites universitaires en france et il
y en a sept qui sont perturbées alors il
y avait un blocage à lyon par exemple
encore quels sont les les universités
concernées
alors il y à un bâtiment à metz un autre
un an signe de mémoire bloquées à rennes
ii actuellement
voilà mes pairs également à bhl a voté
le blocage jusqu'au 2 mai si je ne
m'abuse ce moment on a vu que tolbiac
avaient été évacués dans les conditions
qu'on connaît par les crs
au milieu de la nuit la semaine dernière
et est ce que la même chose au à se
produire à nanterre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous signez un petit peu
la fin de la récré vous siffler la fin
de la récré ou dit bon voilà il ya eu le
temps du débat maintenant il faut que
les examens puissent se tenir
est ce que les forces de l'ordre doivent
procéder de la même manière à nanterre
cattle biac alors à nanterre le
président d'université
un matin en découvrant une bande
d'individus cagoulés et armés de barres
de fer en train de rentrer par
effraction dans un bâtiment a
effectivement on fait appel aux forces
de l'ordre parce qu'ils ne savaient pas
ce qu'ils étaient en train de se passer
et il y avait un réel danger
on n'est plus dans cette situation
actuellement actuellement il est en
train de discuter avec avec les
étudiants de manière à ce que les
examens puissent se tenir normalement au
cours du mois de mai il faut bien
comprendre que les étudiants qui
bloquent les universités actuellement
sont en train de pénaliser les étudiants
qui sont les plus fragiles
les étudiants qui sont que j'ai
travaillé pour payer leurs études les
étudiants boursiers ceux qui ont
absolument besoin d'avoir leur diplôme
pour candidater sur des masters donc la
tenue des examens
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important tous les présidents
d'université ils sont attachés et bien
sûr je ferai en sorte de les aider à ce
que les examens se tiennent dans leurs
locaux ou dans d'autres locaux mais la
semaine dernière on a beaucoup parlé du
blocage de tolbiac la semaine dernière
sept mille étudiants ont passé néanmoins
leurs examens la semaine dernière deux
mille étudiants ont passé leur examen à
montpellier les examens se sont déroulés
à l'est
ils sont en train de se dérouler dans
plusieurs sites universitaires pour
certains ces dernières aient commencé de
cette semaine vous aurez vous aurez a
vaincu ce mouvement de contestation
quand justement tôt l'examen auront été
passés enfin qu'une modalité on va en
parler aussi mais vous estimez que vous
aurez vaincu ce mouvement à ce moment là
moi je crois que c'est très important je
ne cherche pas à vaincre le mouvement je
cherche simplement à comprendre quelles
sont les causes d'inquiétude qui
s'exprime
lorsque ce sont de vraies inquiétudes de
manière à pouvoir expliquer quel est
l'objet de cette réforme et je le
rappelle c'est d'abord une meilleure
orientation ensuite c'est qu'on ne tire
plus au sort les étudiants lorsqu'ils
rentrent à l'université et enfin ces
données à chaque étudiant ce dont il a
besoin pour réussir
et ça c'est quand même assez nouveau moi
j'ai longtemps enseigné en première
année par plaisir parce que pour moi
c'est un plaisir d'enseigner en première
année d'université et je sais très
exactement à quel point c'est difficile
pour les enseignants chercheurs de voir
les amphis se vider au cours des
semaines passées de blocage et aussi
beaucoup de dégâts aujourd'hui à combien
vous estimez ces dégâts sur l'ensemble
des faillites ont été occupées alors les
estimations elles sont en cours toulouse
notamment qui a fait l'objet d'une
énorme rénovation en 2016 la fac le
parmi diverses universités jean jaurès
pour 350 millions d'euros est à priori à
énorme et donc à c'était le coût de la
rénovation
a priori il ya énormément de d'or vous
pouvez nous dire o'shea alors sur
toulouse j'ai pas d'estimation précise
le président de l'université montpellier
iii annonce à peu près 300 mille euros
de dégâts sur les salles de serveurs
l'université je choisis donc sur
l'université de tolbiac à paris les
devis sont en cours mais on parle aussi
de
deux à trois cents mille euros et qui
doit payer au final parce qu'à un moment
c'est des gars il va falloir que
quelqu'un les assume est-ce que vous
encourager les présidents d'université a
porté plainte
est-ce que c'est à ceux qui ont occupé
de finalement assumé le coût de ces
dégâts c'est à l'état de prendre en
charge
on fait comment alors j'ai pas à les
inciter à quoi que ce soit mais
effectivement que certains présidents
d'université font faire des
constatations par la police
effectivement avec pour objectif
derrière de pouvoir porter plainte parce
que c'est important
maintenant comme je voulais dire lorsque
des individus ont été identifiés en
train de casser il était souvent
cagoulés la démonstration va être
difficile mais il n'empêche que c'est
important de savoir qui a commis ces
dégâts parce que effectivement c'est le
contribuable qui qui va payer l'argent
des universités c'est de l'argent public
et voilà donc déjà pour filmer les
universités la difficulté c'est que
évidemment moi je ne souhaite pas que
l'argent qui a été investi notamment
pour mieux accueillir les étudiants
soient utilisés pour repeindre des
amphis ou refaire des serveurs donc
voilà c'est je serai à côté des
présidents pour trouver avec les
meilleures solutions qui ne pénalise pas
leur université
mais pas d'estimation du coût global
alors on part je pense qu'on dépassera
le million d'euros le million d'euros
pour l'ensemble de l'univers du conte en
a on est déjà quasiment 600 milles s'il
est dur mais qui donc toulouse comme ça
que vous avez vécu ce week-end la rumeur
d'un étudiant plongé dans le coma après
l'intervention des forces policières à
tolbiac est ce que vous avez
réagit est ce que vous considérez que
ceux qui ont propagé cette rumeur
doivent s'excuser il ya des médias de de
la france insoumise l'unef également
accréditer la thèse de cet étudiant dans
le coma j'ai trouvé ça absolument
abjecte il n'ya pas eu d'étude encore
non non bien sûr que non je confirme
qu'il ya eu des étudiants de coma je
trouve que c'est abject je reprendrai
volontiers les mots de raphaël enthoven
sur le sujet c'est voilà je crois qu'il
a dit que l'étudiant blessés que l'on
invente
c'est peut-être le mort que l'on
souhaite je trouve que c'est
incroyablement violent de faire ça je
trouve que c'est une voie là c'est pour
moi c'est inadmissible c'est
inqualifiable
je pense à nos gens qui ont le malheur
de perdre quelqu'un de jeune dans leur
entourage dans leur famille faire passer
ce type de rumeur effectivement ce donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on cherche
vraiment on sent chez vous vous attendez
peut-être les excuses aujourd'hui je
souhaitais explique moi je j'attends
tout au moins que les personnes qui ont
colporté ces rumeurs effectivement
reconnaissent que ces rumeurs sont
fausses
g j'ai noté effectivement sur quels
types de médias elle avait été propagée
par quel type de personne
le média seulement dans le média qui qui
a avait l'air de se réjouir absolument
de cette nouvelle qui lui a permis de
faire du buzz
je trouve que c'est tout sauf du
journalisme
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce mouvement de
notre époque
plus globalement parce qu'on parle aussi
beaucoup de ces fakes news qui se
propage qu'on a du mal à endiguer qu'est
ce que ça dit de notre époque de ce
mouvement
sadi probablement que au moins pour
partie il y a une envie d'
instrumentaliser des choses et une envie
de se mettre en scène ya une envie de
théâtre et une envie de faire croire que
les quelques centaines d'étudiants qui
bloque représentent la majorité des
étudiants chaque fois qu'une
consultation électronique est fait
l'écrasante majorité des étudiants sont
contre le blocage souhaite passer
examen c'est un peu la démocratie
confisquée
lorsqu'on organise des regroupements
dans lesquels ont interdit l'accès à
certains étudiants parce qu'ils ne
partagent pas les idées lorsque l'on
tags des locaux de l'union des étudiants
juifs de france
lorsqu'on écrit sur les murs un bon flic
est un flic mort la semaine où on
célèbre le colonel beltrame et on à
l'attentât de trêve
voilà lorsqu'on est capable de faire ce
genre de choses c'est que on veut
instrumentaliser les universités on veut
instrumentaliser les étudiants et
l'université ne se laisse pas
instrumentaliser en tout cas moi j'en
suis convaincu en tant qu'universitaire
vous avez été heurté par certains
ateliers qui se sont tenues dans
certaines facs je couvrirai cantonniers
en non mixité ou union raciste raciste
vous avez là certains mettent en cause
par exemple la présence des indigènes de
la république dans l'organisation de ces
manifestations
oui vous confirmer on est dans un
contexte qui n'a plus rien d'un contexte
universitaire c'est vraiment ça qu'il
faut comprendre tolbiac n'avait plus
rien d'un contexte universitaire les
lieux où se tiennent ces ateliers n'ont
plus rien d'un contexte universitaire et
puis en temps professeur de génétique
je vous confirme qu'il n'ya qu'une race
humaine alors en tous les cas
l'intervention de des forces de police
c'était le thème de notre première
question du sondage opinionway pour
l'épreuve de vérité
est ce que vous êtes pour l'appel aux
forces de l'ordre pour empêcher le
blocage des universités 59% jeu 2 oui
38% de nom
on n'est pas surprise par ce résultat
mais je crois que la façon dont on pose
la question est compliquée à la fois
bien sûr qu' il faut empêcher blocage
dans les universités bien sûr que les
universités on vous l'avait rappelé
l'habitude d'accueillir du débat parfois
de la contestation
et c'est uniquement lorsque les
présidents d'université ne se sente cuir
en capacité d'assurer la sécurité sur
leur propre campus que les forces de
l'ordre interviennent et là c'est normal
parce que on n'est plus dans un contexte
d'université